الليلة نريد أن نضع بعض
التفاصيل الجديدة المثيرة للقلق حول حرب روسيا الوحشية
ضد الشعب الأوكراني ،
سنبدأ بإشارات تحذير جديدة
للكرملين يفكر في استخدام
سلاح نووي تكتيكي الآن
تعتقد المخابرات الأمريكية أن كبار
الجنرالات الروس ناقشوا كيف
ومتى يتم نشر هذا
التقرير السري الذي تم وصفه لشبكة CNN من قبل عدة
مصادر قرأته ، هناك نقاش
حول مدى جدية أخذ هذه
المعلومات الاستخباراتية ، هل هي علامة أخرى على
اليأس الروسي وتسبب قلقًا حقيقيًا
أم أن هذه المناقشات تم
إخراجها من سياقها.  على شبكة CNN في وقت سابق
اليوم ، رد جون كيربي ، مسؤول الأمن القومي في البيت الأبيض ،
على
أحدث تقرير استخباراتي أمريكي ،
هناك الكثير من
مستويات القلق بشأن ما يحدث
في أوكرانيا في الوقت الحالي ، وهو ما يعطينا
سببًا لمواصلة المراقبة عن كثب قدر
المستطاع.  أه قدرات روسيا النووية
الآن التقرير الاستخباراتي يقول أن
فلاديمير بوتين لم يكن جزء منها
المحادثات لكن بوتين علنًا
باحتمال استخدام جهاز نووي
لأشهر اليوم أصدرت وزارة
الخارجية الروسية بيانًا
ربما لمحاولة تهدئة المخاوف من استمرار
سياسة الكرملين المتمثلة في استخدام
الأسلحة النووية فقط في رد دفاعي
معلنة اقتباس أن سلاحًا نوويًا.
لا يمكن كسب الحرب ولا يجب خوضها أبدًا ،
كما أعلن بوتين اليوم أنه سيلتزم مرة
أخرى بصفقة تسمح
بصادرات الحبوب الحيوية من الممر الآمن لأوكرانيا
في البحر الأسود والتي ستكون
بمثابة انعكاس مرحب به لأولئك الذين يخشون من
الجوع العالمي أزمة الجوع أوكرانيا
وتمثل روسيا ما يقرب من
ثلث صادرات القمح في العالم ، وهنا سفير الولايات المتحدة
لدى الأمم المتحدة على شبكة سي إن إن
هذا الصباح من الواضح أن روسيا مقتنعة أخيرًا
أنهم بحاجة إلى مواصلة
هذا الأمر ، ولا يمكنهم الوقوف في طريق
إطعام العالم بأسره
ولكن بوتين  يهدد أيضًا
بالانسحاب من تلك الصفقة مرة أخرى إذا شعر أن
أوكرانيا تستخدم الوصول إلى البحر الأسود
لأي أغراض عسكرية.
ستكون الأسمنت موضع ترحيب إذا
أخذت الكرملين في كلمته ، لكننا
شهدنا جميعًا لحظات كثيرة
يقول فيها الكرملين شيئًا واحدًا ثم يفعل
العكس تمامًا سواء أصر على أنه
لن يغزو أوكرانيا أبدًا أو أنه
سيسمح بمرور آمن للاجئين
ويفوز.  لإلحاق الضرر بهم على الإطلاق أو الوعد
بالسماح بتصدير الأعشاب الضارة ثم التراجع
عن هذا التعهد ، لذلك بينما نأمل جميعًا أن
تثبت تصريحات اليوم دقتها ،
فإننا لسنا على ثقة من أن
ما نحن واثقون منه هو
استمرار الفظائع الروسية.
ستقدم لك كلاريسا وارد من سي إن إن على أرض الواقع في أوكرانيا الليلة
دليلاً جديدًا على هذه
الرعب حيث تتابع المحققين
المكلفين بالبحث عن حالات
الاغتصاب والعنف الجنسي الأخرى داخل
ابنها وهي منطقة تم تحريرها مؤخرًا من
الاحتلال الروسي للأسف.  يعزز
ما وجده فريق تحقيق مستقل تابع للأمم المتحدة من
اغتصاب
وتعذيب كان الضحايا في بعض الأحيان من
الأطفال في سن الرابعة وما فوق
مرات أُجبرت عائلات الضحايا
على
مشاهدة رئيس إحدى منظمات حقوق الإنسان
التي شاركت هذا العام بجائزة نوبل للسلام ، وهو
يحذر من أن العديد من هذه الجرائم
ستمر بلا عقاب بلا
محاسبة ،
لكن هنا في الولايات المتحدة ،
أنشأت وزارة العدل قسمًا جديدًا في
يونيو.  للتحقيق في هذه الفظائع الروسية في
جرائم الحرب هذه ، وهناك
الآن ضغط من الحزبين لتغيير القوانين الأمريكية
بحيث يكون من الأسهل مقاضاة
الروس على هذه الأعمال المروعة في المحاكم الأمريكية في
حال دخول هؤلاء الروس
إلى الولايات المتحدة
، من الصعب الآن تصديق ذلك ولكن هناك
البعض في روسيا الذين يجادلون في الواقع أن
بوتين لم يكن وحشيًا بدرجة
كافية ونريد أن نسلط الضوء الليلة على
جيش مرتزقة ينبثق
من الظلال ،
دعني أقدم لكم يفغيني براغوسيان
فيرغوسيان ، وهو أوليغارشي روسي
معروف باسم طاه بوتين وله
سبب وجيه أن شركة المطاعم والمطاعم
الخاصة به استضافت فعليًا عشاء
حضره بوتين وقادة العالم
الآخرون بما في ذلك  منذ ذلك الحين ، كان الرئيس جورج
دبليو بوش معروفًا أيضًا
بخدمة الجثث
قبل بضعة أسابيع فقط ، اعترف باغوسيان
بتأسيس مجموعة فاغنر في عام 2014.
ربما سمعت وهمسات حول
فاغنر أنها اعتادت أن تكون مجموعة مرتزقة
خاصة تعمل بالكامل في
لكن في السنوات الأخيرة ، تتبعت سي إن إن
عملاء فاغنر في أوكرانيا
ليبيا السودان موزمبيق مالي وسوريا
تمكنت كلاريسا من الوصول إلى
قاعدة تدريب واغنر في جمهورية إفريقيا
الوسطى لروسيا ، وهذه صفقة مباشرة
يقدمونها للأسلحة
والأحلام وفي المقابل هم  الوصول
إلى الموارد الطبيعية للبلاد
وفي هذه العملية يأملون في إعادة تأكيد
أنفسهم كلاعب رئيسي في هذه
المنطقة
، تتمتع مجموعة Wagner بسمعة مروعة
وترتبط بأي عدد
من انتهاكات حقوق الإنسان بما في ذلك
التعذيب وقطع الرؤوس
التي حذرها كبار المسؤولين الأمريكيين باستمرار
حول التكتيكات الوحشية لمجموعة فاغنر ،
واستبعاد الحكم السيئ والفساد
المتأصل فيه  الديمقراطيات الضعيفة تجعلها
أكثر عرضة للحركات المتطرفة
وكذلك للتدخل الأجنبي
الذي يشمل مجموعة فاغنر المدعومة من الكرملين
والتي تستغل عدم الاستقرار لنهب
الموارد وارتكاب الانتهاكات مع
الإفلات من العقاب
الآن وقد دفعت الحرب الروسية على أوكرانيا
باغوسيان وفاغنر إلى دائرة الضوء حسب
تقديرات المسؤولين الأوكرانيين.  يقاتل ما لا يقل عن
5000 من مرتزقة فاجنر
إلى جانب القوات الروسية في أوكرانيا
حيث وجدوا الكثير من الجنود
بشكل جيد ، ووجد تحقيق سي إن إن أن
فاغنر يقوم بتجنيد قتلة وتجار مخدرات
من السجون مع وعد
بأنهم إذا نجوا من الحرب في أوكرانيا
سيتم منحهم.  أحكام أقصر أو
حتى عفو الآن ، هؤلاء ليسوا
جنودًا سابقين تم سجنهم ،
إنهم رجال مجرمون وحشيون أقسى ،
هذا ما قاله أحد السجناء
لنيك بايتون والش من CNN
إذا كان هذا حقيقيًا ، فأنا جميعًا مع ذلك
إما أن يكون في السجن  لمدة تسع سنوات أو
الخروج في غضون ستة أشهر إذا كنت محظوظًا
ولكن هذا إذا كنت محظوظًا
قام بنفسه
مؤخرًا بشيء كان سيبدو في
يوم من الأيام غير
مفهوم ، وفقًا لمسؤولين أمريكيين ،
واجه براغوسيان بشكل مباشر فلاديمير بوتين بشأن
اعتقاده بأن الجنرالات الروس يسيئون
إدارة الحرب في أوكرانيا وأن
التكتيكات الأكثر عدوانية تحتاج إلى استخدام تكتيكات أكثر عدوانية.